One man’s neuron is another man’s knowledge.
That’s the stance of the Allen Institute  for Brain Science
which released the first open access database
of live human brain cells,
including data on the electrical properties
of nearly 300 cortical neurons
taken from 36 patients.
Plus 3D reconstructions of 100 of those cells.
Working with neurosurgeons,
the Institute acquired healthy cells from the cortex
—the outermost layer of the brain—
from patients undergoing surgery
for epilepsy or brain tumors.
Normally considered medical waste,
these rescued tissues will provide scientists
with a unique resource
for understanding the human brain.
That’s because many studies currently rely on dead
--not living-- human tissue
or on brain cells from animals like mice.